[Music]
Trump is the impression of the year
right you're one of the great
Impressionists what do you go to evolve
this Trump him I don't know where I
don't know what to do with it I don't
know where it's going I keep discovering
hooks I could probably sure that I could
tell you that the friends whom I okay
okay I figured if he starts World War 3
will be in our bunkers he'll still be
selling us on closed-circuit TV you know
we had a fabulous nuclear war was
fabulous well your bumpers up terrific
the Chinese bunkers are disaster then it
gets crazy then it just goes crazy I get
tired when I did George Bush I went from
well this and that and then like three
years later or Ness and I was like well
your Arnold went into outer space yeah
you know I started out doing an Arnold
years ago in the late and I show my
olive was so loved it just was closed a
little bit but then at the end I was
just going like sounds Bradley idea and
then pertain to eat invisible sausage
since the all of us construed and
there were rumors people were talking
now I do I'm very feminine I don't know
why wait a bit Ellucian a little bit of
chance
imagine him getting a manicure okay just
go easy little hands little dania yeah
I'm not Jani down there yeah do you see
them as they someone told me that you
were talking about him on stage is being
kind of a villain like he's a superhero
why well cuz he's got the helicopter
says Trump and the plane everything
Trump and there's giant orange head it's
like he's like a Batman villain to me I
mean you'll never get away with this
Trump you know I think I will
[Applause]
he has the perfect name for Batman
villain from now on you can call me
trump guy never gets a laugh but isn't
that a funny name trump card as a
villain every guy who helped that turn
around
[Applause]
and what's your what's your you have a
Burnie impression I do which because of
first impressions I try to think about
how you could teach people what I
discover with him is he talks in three
or four word increments you know I mean
Larry David obviously is the go-to guy
it looks just like employment but here's
here's Bernie distilled okay what let me
just stand okay yeah what what what I'm
prepared to do what I'm prepared to do I
will find someone with lots of money I
will take their money and give it to the
guy who doesn't have months
that is it is jacket jacket is always up
here when he's yeah see so you gotta add
back to your refresh it he's his jacket
is the whole country to look like his
suit and what about Hillary what's your
what's your take on Hillary Hillary to
me is the little engine that could never
gets tired but you know I feel like Bill
is back there all the time because bill
was the master so she's got a little
earpiece and he's behind the scenes
going big dog little hill big dog come
in baby slow down baby they can't all be
applause lies baby slow down slow down
she's not there just work it so hard we
will do the things that we do until we
don't do them
[Applause]
is a cream takes is a cream
peaches and cream that's got a cold word
to bail out
you